Hello friends of reinforcement learning
for large language models what if I told
you that I had a procedure that could
make reward
go up
doesn't require any extra data or
anything external at all it just makes
reward go up now if this sounds too good
to be true I have to say it's only a
little it's only a little too good to be
true and we'll see what that little is
but it surprisingly seems to work so
this is a paper called reinforced self
training or short rest for language
modeling the main authors are kagler
kulchera Tom Lepa or Le Pain I'm sorry
Tom and
srinivasan and it is by a conglomeration
of Google and deepmind or Google
deepmind not exactly sure which of the
organizations have existed or have
exists at the point in time where this
paper was written although it is a
fairly new paper but it sort of comes
from the deep Google Corner this paper
as I said it has a procedure that fully
rely eyes on the trained model that you
get out of training out of regular log
likelihood training out of a language
model and it's a procedure to just
somehow make reward go up by self
bootstrapping so by producing your own
data and then training on that produced
data now we'll as I said we'll get into
the extra bit that's kind of necessary
here that's not super much spoken about
in the paper itself
they themselves say reinforcement
learning from Human feedback or lhf can
improve the quality of large language
models llm llm outputs by aligning them
with human preferences so they're in the
domain of learning from Human feedback
like taking a language model taking
labeled training data that humans have
annotated or humans have demonstrated
somehow so humans have taken some kind
of text input and have demonstrated how
to do whatever task in this paper that's
translation so we have a data set that
for example has German sentences in it
and we have the corresponding English
sentences done by professional human
translators so from this from this data
set this is a this is a task where you
could apply
rlhf or a setting let's say
um
but you could also just train the model
we'll get into all of these things at at
the moment because reinforcement
learning is a term that kind of gets
stretched in the meantime they say we
propose a simple algorithm for aligning
llms with human preferences inspired by
growing batch reinforcement learning
which we call reinforced self training
given an initial llm policy rest
produces a data set by generating
samples from the policy which are then
used to improve the llm policy using
offline RL algorithms
it's they say it's more efficient than
typical online rlhf methods because the
training data set is produced offline
and so on so this is is as I said a
procedure where you generate your own
data now the entire abstract and the
paper in themselves they don't exactly
mention as I said the core ingredient
which is going to be the reward model
that goes into here
and we'll see entire procedure
so we'll dive in we'll go a little bit
into language model training we'll go a
little bit into reinforcement learning
as such and the combination of the two
and what exactly makes this paper work
and also we'll go a little bit into what
I think is maybe like the the secret
working horse behind the whole method or
at least behind a part of it and uh
something that yeah something that might
actually be an alternative reason of why
this method works better than let's say
rlhf in an online fashion also you'll
notice the return of the mirrored
glasses instead of the dark black
glasses there's actually a funny story
behind why I I have these now and that
story is I can't find the other glasses
so there's that now bear with me as we
go through this paper so let's say you
have just trained your very own language
model and you've done so on a data set
and that data set as we said is
translation
or it has samples from translation so
let's say we have data X and
corresponding labels Y and we have kind
of lots of them X Y X to y
on that data set we can train a
translation model so a translation model
that takes in some X so the model takes
in some X and gives me a corresponding y
hat like what it thinks uh the what it
thinks the output should be now the
question is how can we use this model
here to improve itself
well what we could do is we could simply
take
we could simply take
this X and this y right here and say
well that's kind of a new data point
since these are in a translation model
with a stochastic output that we sample
from they're quite unlikely to be the
exact so let's say that this x is
exactly this x we take it from the data
set right here they're quite unlikely to
be the exact same output so we'll say
well this is kind of like a new data
point so can't we make a second data set
add this right here so the sorry about
that the same X
but in this case we'll pair it with the
Y hat and so let's say this is X1 X1 X2
X3 so X1 y hat one
X2 y hat 2. so we'll just let the model
in for we can even do that multiple
times right so for X2 we can produce
another so y hat hat two another
inference and we'll we'll make like
ourselves a new data set and then we can
just take them together and kind of
train the model further to get
a new model right now what's the problem
the problem with this is kind of you're
eating your own poop so if the model is
good it's going to produce good data but
it's only like the data it's going to
produce if I train on it in expectation
I shouldn't see an improvement right
because
um the data is let's say this good so if
I train on data that's this good I
should get a model that's this good
again so naturally this will somehow
stabilize to the performance that the
model is already at so this by itself
doesn't work
I can't just produce data and then train
on it although someone should maybe
maybe try that actually they do try it
in the paper and it improves which I
find very suspicious but let's just
assume in a in a normal reasonable world
this does not work you can't just
produce data and then train on that data
so what do we do well how about we
somehow somehow figure out which of
these translations are good and which
are bad right so somehow we figure out
oh no this one is really bad
and this one is good too and by the way
in the original data set that one here
is also not not as good right so we just
kind of have a method to strike out the
bad data which gives us only good data
and since we can produce more data we
can even keep the volume of data
constant as we just call down on the bad
data or we can even increase the volume
of the data so the how many data points
we have and then that data set naturally
has a better quality because we just
filter out all the bad examples
and with that better quality data set we
can then go train the next model which
naturally since it's trained on better
data will be of higher quality and again
we can use that next higher quality
model to produce data since that model
is a higher quality the data is already
likely to be of higher quality we can
again use our filtering procedure
and we can create an even better data
set
um this has been done in recent times
quite a number of times like the
um a lot of these instruction automated
instruction tuning data sets are done
like this but that kind of relies on an
external thing so you go to gpt4 and you
tell gpt4 make me a data set and then
you go to gpd4 and say well make me a
harder date to set right and a harder
data set but that relies on gpt4 being
this really good model that you can sort
of suckle uh the quality from by getting
data from it however this here we just
produced data from our from the model
that we've trained
so you'll naturally see that this can
only work if our filtering procedure
that we apply over here and here is
somehow better than you know is somehow
good so if that filtering procedure is
good then we can use it to create ever
better data if that filtering procedure
is bad then it will not give us an
improvement so that's the kind of
missing piece in this paper that they
don't speak about
too much which is they need a reward
model to assess whether any given
created data point is good or bad
and that reward model they don't even
say whether they train their own they
just say kind of from what it's called
metric X now I don't know if that's a
trained like a if if they take the
actual reward model from some other
paper or if they just take the
architecture like the methodology and
somehow train on their own data or
create the reward model from their own
data I don't know I don't actually even
know if it's a trained reward model or
if it's like a heuristic score like blue
or so
um they don't specify that too well and
it is the driving horse behind this
whole methodology so I do believe that
should be highlighted a bit more
but you can see right here what they do
so they do essentially what I said but
in a bit more intricate fashion so given
a language model and as I said this all
starts out with an already trained model
that's kind of Step One is I train a
model and on some kind of task in this
case translations are going from German
to English and then I have version zero
of that model so the first thing I do is
I go through what they call a grow step
in the growth step is where I make this
new data set so I simply take the old
data set specifically I take the X
values of the old data set I run them
through the model and the model produces
these
estimated outputs right it just runs
inference over that and I create this
new data set right here so this original
data set they called D and then the
combined data set they call I believe d
G
yeah so this by now is simply a bigger
data set that is augmented by the Sorry
by the generations of the model itself
does nothing yet it's just a bigger data
set with some synthetic data then they
go into this improve step so in the
improve step they do two things
first they filter that data set and
that's the green procedure right here so
DG becomes sort of filtered DG now I
don't know exactly how to let's say
modulo the filter and the filter
is simply the reward function that you
get from somewhere so just imagine you
have some kind of reward function that
can assess really well if a translation
from German to English is correct or not
you just annotate with that reward model
all the data and then you just filter
you set some kind of threshold and you
say well everything lower reward than
that I don't want in my data set I just
want the higher data set so you take
that DG
you filter it down so you only have good
data and then you train the model on
that and you can see that there is an
inner loop right here so the inner loop
can be executed multiple times that
means if I have my new data set let's
redraw this DG no just DG the new data
set is kind of
this is all of my data and let's assume
it's sorted in this way by the reward so
things on higher up they have higher
reward so the first iteration might be I
go and I just filter
from here so everything above
will be in my in my data set
um
for training but then I do a second step
with the exact same data set so the I
can reuse that data I'll just filter it
down
to higher quality so I retain less of it
but what I retain has higher quality and
I can do that multiple times so I can
reuse that same data multiple times
zip until I just remain with the highest
quality data so this can be an inner
loop on the exact same data set so the
thing that these authors mostly optimize
is how often do I have to generate a new
data set because they say that's the
actual slow part in all of these sort of
self training on reinforcement learning
procedure
so let's so this this would be the inner
loop right and the outer loop would then
be so I have here I've trained a model
here so I have m0
model 0 I train M11
M12 M13 so all of these build upon each
other
and then I use M13 to create an entire
new data set which will become sort of a
bigger data set so I joined the original
data set and I can join it with this new
one from the first step and with the new
one from the Second Step so I use that
to create this and this I can then reuse
multiple times so the inner loop is
simply to reuse the produced data
multiple times simply by consecutively
filtering them down let's contrast this
with true real like true online
reinforcement learning from Human
feedback so the rlhf that's currently
popular is using an algorithm called PPO
proximal policy optimization now this is
an algorithm that um
is quite a basic reinforcement learning
algorithm and it has some kind of a
built-in regularization which is this
proximal part right here we won't look
extremely much into this but essentially
in reinforcement learning you have the
agent and you have the environment right
the agent gets an observation from the
environment and it sends back an action
and then gets a reward and then it
starts all over again
now in language model reinforcement
learning we only have we don't have a
loop actually so there's only one
observation there is one action given
and then there's one reward and then
it's over and then we take the next
sample so every data sample is an
entirely new episode for this so
speaking of reinforcement learning in
these things is due to how we do the
loss and not necessarily that it's
reinforcement learning like it's alphago
and you need to plan multiple steps
ahead and yada yada so
I guess
no you could you could probably view
each token as an action but you still
get the reward at the very end but so in
any case in language mode so this the
agent would be our
large language model or in this case you
also sometimes uh
so Pi would be the policy all of these
things are you can just interchange them
the agent in reinforcement learning has
a policy but we mostly use them
interchangeably the llm is technically
that policy so sampling from the llm
would be the agent's policy or assessing
the likelihood of something the
observation here would be our X so that
would be the German sentence so that
goes into the llm the action would be
the y-hat so whatever the we sample from
the language model so the English
sentence that it thinks is the
translation and then the reward
is given by the reward model so we call
that capital r takes in X it takes in y
hat and optionally it could take in the
the label the reference but
that's only in in this case of
translation scores like below or so they
take in reference translations and they
see how well the given translation
matches with that reference translation
but it could just be a trained reward
model that doesn't need the original
label right here and can just assess
somehow
so if you look at papers like instruct
GP tier so what they do is first they
collect human feedback to to train that
initial model m0 right and they do that
with regular language modeling loss in
this paper they also call this uh
Behavior cloning
so Behavior cloning or language modeling
or all of this is essentially the same
it and they write that down here in a
formula
here here somewhere somewhere
did that paper recently changed now here
it is
so they write it down in this formula
right here
is the lot so here is how it comes to be
they'd simply say
this is this is reinforcement learning
math for language modeling so if I have
a German uh sentence and I want to make
an English sentence out of it this here
is my policy then essentially that's
this is the multiplication operator
that's kind of like
my likelihood of or my distribution of
each token given the previous tokens and
the input sentence so this is the way
for writing the policy for stepwise Auto
regressive sampling right each token
depends on the previous tokens and on
the input
therefore if I have if I have training
data that's great crazy crazy that's the
D right here so I have x i y i pairs
right
um and x i comes from some kind of a
base distribution and y i comes from the
true distribution of uh translated
sentences so human human expert
translations I can Define my loss my log
loss as such so the given that I do the
log this becomes the sum not the
multiplication but essentially you'll
see here this is simply the language
modeling loss so it's an expectation
over my data set
I input X and I simply say
the next token How likely is it given
the previous tokens in X so this is
teacher Force language modeling
what I do in practice is this here is a
big Transformer Network or in this paper
a smaller Transformer Network
that Transformer network will output
some sort of a distribution like a
distribution a soft Max distribution
over its vocabulary one of them is going
to be that true token right here let's
say that's going to be
this one here and I do my soft Max lost
my
I forgot what it's called cross entropy
sorry my cross entropy loss between the
true distribution which is just the
Dirac essentially
the one here and zero everywhere else
and the output of the language model so
this is called log likelihood loss
um it's called Behavior cloning all of
this is essentially I train my language
model on a given data set of input
output pairs
so this would be also what instruct GPT
does in Step 0 where they simply say we
it's also called supervised fine tuning
all these names so we supervised fine
tune uh a language model on a given set
of human annotated data
from that right that's from that we go
into this Loop now if we were to go on
like for example instruct GPT or other
reinforcement learning from Human
feedback papers the second point would
be to somehow create a reward model and
there are different ways and I'll leave
it away exactly for here how you create
this reward model some do it by
collecting more human data right on the
model outputs and so on but you somehow
collect a reward model and then what you
do
is
um
you take data
X input data you output y but instead
instead of now comparing it in a token
by token softmax cross entropy way to
the original uh
reference output by the humans you
simply take the reward model and have it
give you one number at the end the the
difference is you don't get a number per
token you just get one number like in
Behavior cloning you get a number and
you get which token is the correct one
here you don't get any of that you
simply get a number okay so the
the challenge in reinforcement learning
is okay I now have to from that number
learn to do more or less of what I just
did the entire sampling sequence and as
you can imagine that takes a lot of
samples so because I get way less
information I just get one number per
episode I have to I have to use more
samples to get there
and the problem is that inferring this y
hat right here from the llm in this
online fashion is is timely so every
time I want to collect a reward I
actually actively have to run language
model inference to get that reward to
get the training and they say well this
is inefficient what if we could generate
the data once offline
and then just reuse the data multiple
times
um yeah so we generated once using the
model that's exact same thing as here
right we generate data using the model
but then instead of only using that in
the moment once with the reward model
in this way we can reuse it multiple
times and isn't that fantastic
now there are more differences as I said
here
we train with the reward and here we
filter
we filter by the reward model and then
train simply with the regular language
modeling loss
but that's essentially the difference to
the online reinforcement learning
so we can see this paper in
um
so there's an algorithm there's a
graphic explanation so this is the the
graphic explanation and the graphic
explanation essentially says your what
what
um I start with the grow step and after
the grow step I have my my data
distribution right which is maybe like
this that's my data distribution
um in the reward that curve is exactly
replicated over here now what I'll do is
I'll simply filter by the reward model
and say okay everything up here is now
my new data and in the Second Step I
Take the same data and say everything up
here is not my new data and so on
everything up here is now my new data
you can see data gets smaller but
quality of data gets higher again this
is fully reliant on me having some good
reward model which they are very very
vague about where it comes from
um so here they say well our implied
distribution here shifts and shifts and
shifts and that can take the last the
last model from here that I trained on
the super good data and I can grow my
data set again so that I don't keep
shrinking my data can actually produce
more data
so their conclusion is going to be that
more than two growth steps are probably
not worth it uh because again you're
sort of still eating your own poop even
if you filter that poop by quality of
poop you're kind of still eating your
own poop and you may stray away too far
from the original data because your
model learns something the distribution
of what the output is not the
distribution anymore of the training
data and even though you keep the
training data in that it's
yeah you still have a distribution shift
over time there's actually multiple
issues now that I that I think of it so
they say well we keep the original data
always around we always do the original
data Union with
whatever comes out of that grow step
right and that together they call the G
for the particular step so sampling from
the model always goes here now think
about it so they say well we keep this
data around and therefore
you know we always kind of stay close to
the training day so this is kind of a
regularizer yes but
you filter both data sets right this is
both this is DG you filter both of them
by the threshold
so if you do that you're always going to
strike away at least part of that
original data now because you train your
models using the reward model to ever to
produce ever higher rewards right
naturally probably if we always produce
the same amount of data that means that
whatever part is here I don't know how
they call it
will be will increase in its rewardiness
because it comes from a model that has
been trained to produce ever higher
reward while the original data will stay
constant which means in expectation and
it would be nice to confirm that
experimentally somehow but in
expectation of the original data more
and more should be slashed Away by given
the the same settings of the filter or
the same percentile of filters right
because naturally this state is going to
rise in reward and the original data
stays constant given the same reward
model more and more of that original
data is just gonna not be inside of the
filtered version
of the G at all so not only do we train
the model to successively conform to the
reward model but we even slash away the
data that would prevent it from doing so
and stay close to the original data so
there's it's kind of like a double a
double whammy uh for that and only come
to think of this right now so yeah that
might be a reason why too many growth
steps aren't ideal
um because they observe as well no
matter how good your reward model is
these techniques they come to what's
called reward hacking where they abuse
kind of the differences or the the
details of the reward model to get very
high reward but to not to like
what the humans say is good and what the
reward model says is good are kind of
too they're similar but they're two
different things and these methods are
very good at exploiting details of the
reward model so they can get high reward
without actually producing higher
quality data it's kind of like an
adversarial attack on the reward model
now they say online reinforcement
learning suffers much more from that
than they do and they they claim that in
part this is because they keep this
original data around but I'm not exactly
sure because they keep kind of slashing
it on the other hand they also say you
know more than one or more than two
growth steps is probably
are not sufficient and again I wonder
because the main Improvement Here Comes
definitely from filtering by the reward
model so what happens if we just use the
same original model like the one from G1
to produce more data and then filter
that do we really need the new model
here to produce that new data because it
seems like the crucial aspect is going
to be the filtering done by the reward
model so couldn't this model here also
just produce more data or is it about
diversity of data like I wonder right
what if I just use the original or the
very like
Theta 0 Pi zero or Theta 0 to produce
all of kinds of data right I just let it
sample sample sample sample and then I
always filter that and once I have very
little data I just sample some more
um
yeah maybe that's why multiple growth
steps are just not super interesting
because
could I do this with one model or is the
fact that I now have a new model that's
higher reward somehow
like for sure I have to sample less but
sorry these are just thoughts that that
come to mind so here is the
full algorithm outline and we'll get to
the experimental section in a bit but I
have one more gripe first with this so I
don't want to dunk on it too much right
it's it's a nice technique and
what it reveals
so the whole the whole paper
could actually be renamed you could
rewrite the whole abstract or the whole
reasoning behind the paper which is
essentially like how can we
first how can we make the best out of
the data we have which seems to be not
optimal so far right if we can improve
our models by like sampling from
ourselves and you know techniques like
this it necessarily means we don't have
a the best use of our data figured out
while we're training for the first time
that's that's just that the second thing
is the paper could just as well be like
you know scrap all of that and it's just
how if I have like a really good reward
model how can I make the best use of
that because that's what the paper does
right it's like we have a really good
reward model how can we make the best
use of it
online PPO is probably not as good as
what they are doing right here but
that's essentially how I see the paper
Okay so the full algorithm
goes as follows
as you can see we have all these inputs
and among the inputs is that reward
model okay so that's
as I said
The crucial part here that actually
makes the whole thing work
in the growth step
we generate the data set by sampling so
this is the original data set and we
Union it with this one right here we
take the X from the original data set
and the Y is inferred by our current
policy so by our current
most recently trained model
so train we uh
produce a number of data and then we
simply annotate it with the reward model
so during the growth step we don't do
anything we simply grow our data and now
during the improve step
two two steps first choose a threshold
right
and then just filter the data by that
threshold choose a threshold for reward
and they also train value models here
that they speak about this I believe in
the appendix a little bit but you simply
choose a threshold
how you choose that threshold
in one point they say well we have a
list
of thresholds that we try in other
points they say well we sort of trainer
or a value function and then we decide
according to that
I don't know
but
while the reward improves on an eval set
optimize the objective
and the objective here is simply the
normal normal language modeling loss
multiplied by this F term right here and
the F term is simply the filter by the
reward model so it's just a mathy way of
writing
I filter my data you can see right here
the F term is a indicator function that
is one whenever the reward of the pair
is higher than the threshold and the
zero otherwise
so that
that multiple yeah I get it why they do
it but it's it's kind of like we haven't
had like a full full uh width formula
for a while so quick throw in some math
right here good job good job
effective mathification
um so they train on this new objective
on the filter data set
now if you
analyze this a little bit and they do
right here
and say we have a what they call a
probabilistic interpretation and
essentially they say if you look at the
gradient of this loss the gradient comes
from two different parts right since our
data set consists of two different sets
the original data set and this new
self-produced data set we can also split
up the loss into two different parts so
the loss essentially you can see right
here the x is always sampled from the
data set for the part that comes from
the original data set
the Y is sampled from the true
distribution so we can also say y comes
from the original data set here
um but that's like human annotate like
super Oracle labels uh there is it's
simply a filtered version of the
language modeling loss so this right
here this is the log likelihood loss
that you saw before the gradient of that
and it's simply filtered by the data
they claim okay this is kind of a this
is kind of a regularizer the second term
on the right hand side we consider the
original data but we still ensure that
it passes the threshold intuitively
people choose D According to some
possible criteria yada yada
yada yada the last term is therefore a
form of offline policy gradients which
prevents it to move too far from the
original distribution which could lead
to model collapse
some sort of proximal term
the first part however you can see right
here it's the same term
however
the Y now is the one you sampled so this
now here we're in full reinforcement
learning mode because we are taking the
log likelihood
of the input with respect to our own
output okay and this is if you don't
know about sort of reinforcement
learning policy gradients
um you you will have X you will have
your policy or your model create y hat
and then what you do is you just kind of
pretend that that's your that's the pair
of data points and you
ask what's the loss of this right
um
sorry I've I'm explaining this
explaining this terribly
maybe I should explain it like this hmm
so
what your model will do with X is it
will give you a distribution right
okay now
this this is the distribution under the
model so Pi of x
so all of these are potential actions
potential y hats right and if let's just
say we take the biggest ones today we do
greedy sampling we say okay this is my
output right here right this is the
action I want to take so this is my y
hat you just pretend that that's the
true label so you just pretend
that you know that is the actual label
so you take from your own output and you
just can't kind of pretend that's the
true label okay and then you train with
that so instead of having the Gold Label
here right by the humans which could be
any of these labels and if it's this one
right then we were really wrong because
this was a smaller uh smaller log it
but in this case we just take our own
output and we make it into the label and
then we just apply the loss now if we
were to just do that we would just sort
of
if this is right then good then we make
this bar go up next time but if it's
wrong we also make the bar go up next
time right so it would not it's like
training on our own data right it would
not help so what we need to do is we
need to scale it in classic
reinforcement learning we actually have
the reward
times the loss with respect to our own
data now if the reward is high that
means we want that bar to go up because
if the reward is high we've actually
done something good and we want to do it
next time more if the reward is low we
want we don't want that bar to go up we
actually want all the others to go up so
what usually people do is they replace
the reward actually by an advantage
function that's simply their scaled
reward so that's positive if the reward
goes high and it's negative actually if
the reward goes low which means that it
would even if we are wrong right if our
model is wrong it wouldn't push that bar
down and push all the others up
right so
um that's regular reinforcement learning
and I believe that's what proximal
policy optimization does as well now
what we do here is something very very
similar
so notice that the similarity between
what they do training on their own data
right and what this reinforcement
learning ways do they are in a way also
training on their own data like training
on data that they have produced except
that they produce it in the Moment by
outputting the distribution sampling
from it getting a self-inferred label
and then using that as a training sample
in the moment whereas this method does
it more explicitly it first produces
data by itself and then it trains
against that data now speaking of
efficiencies
doesn't that mean essentially we do at
least two times the forward pass for
each sample like once when we create the
data set and then when we train against
it and in this case right here we only
do one time the forward pass because we
can then do the backward pass in the
moment so
all of the argument of this being more
efficient
you have to at least train twice on the
same data to make that claim
but I guess they do
you can see here we don't scale by the
reward but we scale by this filter
function
this filter function is of course
dependent on the reward but it's not the
reward the filter function is one if the
reward is I and the filter function is
zero if the reward is low okay so they
even claim this um
as you can see right here similar to
online policy gradient replacing the
state action value function when
starting in state X and taking
sequential actions y
that is generating synthetic data while
using the policy in our context
so my question is
how much influence does this have
because in all of these methods you have
to regularize these things somehow
otherwise they quickly collapse right so
because if you just let them do this RL
thing they will just sort of reward hack
and collapse and mode collapse and so on
so you sort of need to to treat them
very carefully and you need to make it
such that they don't go away from the
original objective too much so you
produce your own data here right but the
original data is actually the true data
so proximal policy optimization and many
many other reinforcement learning
techniques they have regularizers built
in to not have them stray away too far
and they hear they don't naturally have
a regularizer like this in fact they
filter down the same data more and more
to just the the higher
higher quality things now they say we
decrease the learning rate as that goes
on they also say well the right hand
side here is kind of like a regularizer
because we keep the original data in
there but as I said we also filter down
that more and more and more so my
question is and that's not something
that's answered in the paper how much of
a regularizer how much is it actually
this thing right here that ultimately
does all of this regularization work the
fact that you don't provide a number for
the reward or for the advantage but just
a one or a zero like you've been you we
essentially regularize the the
coarseness uh or the quantization of the
reward itself
and thus we kind of smooth because
otherwise
the loss wants to make the reward go
really high right and if for one sample
it's 0.8 then for another sample it's
0.9 right that's a difference so it can
make it always go higher it can make it
you know if even if it's 0.9 it can make
it go 0.95 or so and we know that you
know this this just leads to
it or it could lead to all of those
reward hacking behaviors where it just
focuses on the highest rewards and
getting them as high as possible whereas
here there's just one or zero right in
the zero we don't even train on it so
there is just it's just completely
regularized and smoothed my question
would be what if we take this loss and
instead of multiplying by the filter
function we also we just
also multiplied by the reward right what
would what would happen then and
well I guess
I guess that would result in the online
way again so we we would have to find an
in-between like there's an in-between of
filtering and modeling multiplying by
the reward like sort of us have a
sigmoid in there or something like this
anyway that this is my question sort of
the the hard braking and thus the
essentially smoothing of the reward of
anything that's above the filter to the
same level how much regularization does
that contribute and is that positive or
not
so that is
but that is essentially the
interpretation right here as you can see
there is a proximal term over here which
we don't exactly know what influence it
as and there is a filter instead of the
reward function as it would be in on
policy learning or in the online
reinforcement learning case which we
also don't exactly know what the
influence is
but with their technique they can reuse
the same produced data multiple times by
just setting multiple filter settings
and focusing on ever higher reward
um
things and what that results in is
reward go up that's where we were at the
beginning so reward go up
in this case just for one grow step so
one time they produce more data as you
see for example here g equals one and
already then as they do these inner
improved step filtering down more and
more
reward goes up
and sure there is sort of a negative
second derivative but still
um it seems to be you know goes up
pretty well
now they say right here
on each data set we report results with
behavior cloning so this is the original
the original
model right here and what I also find
interesting is that they always have
this in here this g equals 1 I equals
zero
now
what that is according to their own
claim is we do one growth step and we do
zero Improvement steps now from an
algorithm perspective this doesn't even
make sense because
the optimization happens inside the
improved step which starts from one so
if I don't do any of that I shouldn't
even be training the model at all like
the model is never touched according to
their own algorithm but in the text they
kind of describe what they mean what
they mean is we just grow the data set
and we don't do any filtering and as you
can see we already improve and that is
something that I find like a little bit
suspect
like just a little bit no no one else
does
in fact they have a comparison down here
where
look
so you have this model and you do online
RL like you do online reinforcement
learning a PPO or whatever with with
maybe with the same reward model I hope
it's the same reward model and you get
71.6 and just by growing your own data
and just training language modeling on
that grown data half of which is the
original data set
you got more
without any filtering just by eating
your own poop you just get better result
than
online RL which sort of has powered
like the advances to chat GPT and so on
that this is what I find a little bit
suspect about here and I'm not entirely
sure
why that would be
um I have some imaginations first that
the RL was not handled super well second
that the reward model is just kind of
I don't know wonky
um it's maybe good but but wonky I don't
know
the other thing is that
and they they self say in their model
section that their models are a bit
small so my question would be how
small and might that smallness have
something to do with
or have they just not trained them
really well right for some reason if I
can just train on some sample data and
get a higher reward than a procedure
that is you know
that is dedicated to maximizing the
reward
something's wrong
right okay in any case if they then do
the actual Improvement steps and even
more growth steps they get a higher and
higher and higher reward
but we are looking on this with a bit of
suspicion suspicion
yeah so they show how if they do
multiple growth steps you can see right
here
and then do Improvement steps inside of
that then
um they get they get even better it
would be cool to see to have sort of a
matrix right here because they say well
the growth steps and the Improvement
steps they're kind of uh
they're sort of data set dependent and
so on like how many are optimal and so
you kind of need to babysit but I would
also be interested what happens if I
then take this model and just do another
growth step or the I equals one and then
you know you know what I mean like I
always do a growth step like what what
are the trade-offs here this isn't super
well explored
um yeah but they say for most data sets
more than two growth steps aren't really
helping too much
yeah so that was the paper they do some
other experiments too and they use human
raters and this is quite interesting the
human raters essentially say yes this
method is better
than the uh
than the standard language model that
the the base language model however it's
not proportional so you can see here the
by how much it is better is not
proportional to sort of the Improvement
that they see on the reward of the on
the evaluation data sets so this still
means that there are word models and the
human
ratings they still are a bit distinct
and you know it pays to to view to that
that's it's almost an orthogonal
Direction but it's interesting that they
included that here which is very cool
so this was the paper as I said it's an
interesting procedure
why it works is so the technical reason
why it works is obviously
in my mind I would have said is the
reward model that just comes from
somewhere and is really good right and
using its power and its knowledge we we
sort of distill it into the models using
this techniques however on the flip side
it seems that if you just do the growth
step and use no reward model at all you
get better too which again I find I'm
not I would have set the reward model is
the Workhorse here
um on the other hand it raises question
on just how effectively do we use data
and do we have all of what's there to
figure out about training like just the
supervised fine-tuning part is there do
we have figured out all there is to
figure out I don't know
um I'll leave that to you leave me a
comment on what you think is going on
and I'll see you around bye